problema número 76 cuál de las
siguientes proporciones es casi igual a
la proporción 1 + raíz de 52
aquí lo importante es encontrar cuál es
la raíz cuadrada de 5 veamos como no nos
dejan usar calculadora
yo sé que 2 es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 4 y sé que 3 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 9
así que la raíz cuadrada de 5 estará más
cercano a la raíz cuadrada de 4 que hará
de raíz cuadrada de 9 veamos cuánto es
2.1 al cuadrado 2.1 por 2.1 es igual
y dos sacan sumamos 144 tenemos 12
puntos decimales o bueno dos lugares
después del punto decimal y lo vamos a
mover de aquí a acá es 4.41 y todavía
podemos acercar un poco más cuánto es el
cuadrado de 2.2 2.2 por 2.2 es igual a
44 aquí me falta un 0 por cierto aquí el
factor 0 44 sumamos esto de hecho esto
también es rosa
484 creo que es lo más que nos podemos
aproximar a 5 entonces va a ser 2.2 lo
que se acerca a la raíz cuadrada de 5 y
vamos a sustituir esto este 2.2 acá uno
más 2.2 entre 2 esto es igual a 3.2
entre 2 y como las opciones están
expresadas como enteros vamos a
aproximar este resultado a un entero ok
esto es igual a 1.6
y vemos la primera opción es ocho
quintos la primera opción es ocho
quintos es igual a uno
por tres quintos que nos da lo mismo que
1.6 así que esta es la opción correcta
la opción
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 77 7 entre un quinto más 5 entre
un séptimo a que es igual vamos a
resolverlo esto es igual a 7 por 5 entre
+ 5 x 7 / 1
esto es igual a 7 por 5 35 5 por 7 35 y
en la suma de esto da igual a 70 que es
nuestra opción de
muy bien siguiente problema problema
número 78 desde el primero de enero de
1991 hasta el primero de enero de 1993
de personas involucradas en
organizaciones de salud se incrementó 15
por ciento el número de personas
involucradas al primero de enero de 1993
eran 45 millones cuántas de estas
personas estaban involucradas al primero
de enero bueno nos dicen entonces que en
el año 91 hacia el año 93 se incrementó
15 por ciento la cantidad de personas
involucradas y nos dicen que del 93
había 45 millones lo que nos preguntan
es cuántos había en el 91 x es lo que
nos preguntan la cantidad de personas
involucradas en cuestiones de salud en
1991 cuando x se incrementó el 15 por
ciento fue cuando nos dio estos 45
millones así que está x
0.15 que es el 15% que se incrementó
esta misma equis nos da 45 sumamos a
esto un 1.15 x igual a 45
x va a ser igual a 45
45 entre 1.15
esto vamos a resolver un 1.15 vamos a
hacer esta operación nuestra división es
45 entre 1.15 vamos a recorrer esto este
punto acá 2 lugares entonces aquí vamos
a agregar dos ceros para mover el punto
de aquí acá y vamos podemos agregar unos
ceros más no nos va a estorbar aquí va a
estar el punto decimal vamos a
multiplicar esto por 3
3 x 5 15 llevamos 13 x 13 no es una 43
por una 3
hacemos estas restas 50 1 105 bajamos un
cero ahora vamos a multiplicar esto por
9 más o menos 9 por 5 45 llegamos 49 por
19 + 4 13 llevamos 19 por una nueva zona
aunque jesse se aproxima bastante
restamos aquí va a ser 5 aquí va a ser 1
y aquí queda 0 15 y vamos a ver cuál es
el primer decimal acá o cuál cuál es el
número después del punto decimal y bueno
aquí sólo me queda multiplicarlo por 1
esto es 115 150 menos 115 es igual
535 no voy a continuar más porque con
esto me estoy dando cuenta que está más
cercano a 39 si hubieras ido' 39.9 lo
hubiera redondeado más hacia 40 más que
a 39 así que está x es es
aproximadamente igual a 39.1 y la opción
más cercana es la opción b muy bien
siguiente problema problema número 79 r
es un conjunto de enteros nones
positivos y menores a 50 y ese es el
conjunto de cuadrados de r cuántos
elementos contiene la intersección entre
ese r básicamente tenemos que ver
cuántos enteros non es positivos menores
a 50 son cuadrados de otros enteros
nones positivos menores de 50 y no nos
lleva mucho encontrar los cuadrados de 0
a 50 los cuadrados van a ser 1
36 me falta el 49 7 por 7 49 ok y estos
deben ser no les no pares así que de
aquí quitamos al 4 al 16 al 36 y vemos
que uno cumple porque uno es el cuadrado
de 11 por 11 9 es el cuadrado de 33 x 39
y es non 25 también cumple porque es el
cuadrado de 55 x 125 y es non finalmente
49 también cumple porque es el cuadrado
de 7 y es mamá así que tenemos 4
elementos en la intersección de estos
dos conjuntos que es nuestra opción c
siguiente problema programa número 80
una tienda de electrodomésticos vende
una videograbadora con un 20% más que el
precio al que él adquirió de 200 si un
empleado aplica el descuento del 10%
para empleados para comprar esta
grabadora cuánto pagará el empleado por
ella bueno tenemos que nuestro dato lo
vamos
llamarle p al precio que vendieron esta
grabadora que es de 1.2 por el precio
original que era de 200 ese es el precio
de venta esto es lo que cualquier
persona tendría que pagar si no fue
empleado de la tienda pero un empleado
tiene el 10% de descuento un empleado
tendrá el 10% de descuento de este
precio
así que sustituimos está aquí y nos va a
quedar que lo que paga el empleado es
igual a 0.9 de 1.2 por 200
veamos cuánto es 200 por 1.2
cuánto es eso es 400 y 1 por 200 es 200
sumamos
y nos queda 24.000 pero tenemos aquí un
lugar después del punto decimal por lo
que aquí lo recorremos 1 y nos queda que
es 240 esta parte de aquí son 240 o sea
es el o sea es el precio al que venden
la grabadora normalmente pero todavía
nos falta aplicar el descuento para
empleados esto este 240 lo vamos a
multiplicar por punto 9.9
9 % 09 por 436 llevamos 3 9 por 2 18 y 3
21 tenemos aquí un lugar después del
punto decimal así que lo recorremos de
aquí acá y nos queda que 216 es lo que
tuvo que pagar el empleado para comprar
esta grabadora y es nuestra opción de
opción ve y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo